27 years after the horrors of the
bosnian war
remains of the dead are still being
identified still being buried
on the anniversary of the genocide at
srebrenica 50 more victims were laid to
rest they're suffering long over but not
forgotten
well it's easier when you know where
their graves are even if we bury only a
couple of bones
when you think of their suffering when
you think of what they've been through
i just can't explain how i feel
time survivors say does not heal all
wounds
every
next anniversary is somehow more
difficult than the previous one
the time
takes its toll
and
it's not an easy day i can tell you that
much it's
not an easy time of the year for any one
of us
myself included
in the closing months of the war serbian
forces overran the town of srebrenica
within 10 days they slaughtered more
than 8 000 mostly muslim men and boys
so far the remains of more than 6
600 people have been found and buried as
the work of dna investigators continues
funerals are likely to remain a regular
part of annual remembrance events
the women of srebrenica have had an
outsized role in keeping the memory of
what happened alive
[Music]
my being here
is
a symbol of
the world the united nations saying
thank you to the mothers of srebenita
thank you for the courage that they have
had to carry these messages across
thank you for not giving up thank you
for the fact that they keep
leading efforts to find the efforts of
those who are killed during the genocide
here in sribanita
an estimated one hundred 000 lives were
lost in a war fought along ethnic lines
from 1992 to 1995.
since russia's invasion of ukraine and a
return of war to europe
bosnians worry instability could spill
over to the balkans and ignite tensions
once again
zayn basravi al jazeera
tariq demisevich is in srebrenica for us
the site of the genocide is as now as
we've seen there a place of remembrance
what's been happening there on this
sombra day
approximately 50 000 people have been
have gathered here today to commemorate
the victims of the genocide but not just
to commemorate also to bury 50
of the victims and that is one uh
there is a thing that makes this
gathering in srebrenica every year on
the 11th of july specific this is not
just a commemoration of
to the genocide victims it is their
burial this is an ongoing process
process for 27 years now not all victims
have been buried not all victims have
been
found up to this point around 1200 of
them are still
considered missing the other point that
makes srebrenica and this gathering here
on this day specific is that this is a
remembrance and a commemoration of for
the victims of a genocide this is the
only genocide in the world apart from
the one in rwanda
that was found to be a genocide
confirmed and proved in uh by the
judiciary both on the national level but
also by the international
courts and to try to explain how this
how the courts came to this conclusion
to to try to explain the scale of
crimes committed here uh that was
committed here uh by the serbian forces
by the bosnian serbian forces 27 years
ago i will walk you through a personal
story of one hatija mehmed the
late hathija
once said to uh you know in a private
conversation i feel sometimes ashamed
because i only speak of my sons i only
pray for my sons hardly ever do i
mention
my husband and my husband was such a
great such a great man
27 years ago in july hathija lost two of
her sons her husband three of her
brothers and her father and that's just
the immediate family of hers and that
shows the scale of crimes committed here
27 years ago in cebu
tariq many things